NARRATOR: But imagine seeing
the park with fresh eyes,
and every view a rare
glimpse into a hidden
world just like this one.
A black bear and her cubs,
a typical litter of three.
For five months,
she hasn't stirred.
Even as their mother slumbered,
the cubs nursed on a rich diet
of super-fatty milk.
Over the winter, her own
weight dropped up to 1/3.
How she survived
still stumps us.
During hibernation, her heart
rate fell to just eight bits
per minute, and somehow, she
turned much of her bodily waste
into protein.
In the coming months,
she must fatten
up on what the forest provides.
The survival of the fragile
cubs depends on their mother.
Her survival depends
on the Smokies.
After weeks confined
to a cubbyhole,
new life makes its
debut in the park.
Black bears are born
climbers with strong claws.
Even a bear cub negotiates the
trunk like a power lineman.
Their debut draws attention.
Our mom must stay alert.
Coyotes will prey on the cubs.
So will bobcats.
At night, the treetops
offer refuge from predators
that can't climb.
In daylight on the ground,
the cubs are vulnerable,
so mom won't let them wander.
For the next 18 months,
they'll shadow their mother,
their instructor and protector
within a park that safeguards
them from another enemy, man.
Male cubs will grow
up to be loners
like their long-gone father.
Females will rear
their own offspring.
For now, three
wide-eyed toddlers
enter a world made
for them, if they
learn to make the most of it.